we
love parts
to it and
fly with you friends 30 people
volunteers
you are a
dick and last night
you are
going to
iphone considered
jokes
lavrov on a security the value of your
israeli you sit and draw your
final one finger of the mummy's [ __ ] ass is
red and has time and the brothers are just
very  samples for pasha stayed at the concert
where we discussed ukraine today our
american colleagues tried again
how do you put the
problems on the border between russia and ukraine at the forefront and
tried to condition everything else on the
need for the so-called go
escalation this has already become such a
spell but i will emphasize once again
final  As a result, we concluded with an
agreement that we will be
presented with written
answers to all our proposals next week. Russia
has never never threatened the Ukrainian people through the mouths of its
official representatives.
Zelinsky’s gift
that you took under your wing, our
Western colleagues patronize him,
encouraging him to any antics, said  P  publicly
that if someone feels like a
Russian citizen of Ukraine, then let him
leave Ukraine for Russia,
and he called those who in the Donbas
oppose
state terrorism by the
Kiev regime not people and
individuals, as you remember, who threatens whom,
what are these threats  a
big question may arise, we do not rule out
that all this hysteria that
our Western colleagues are now unwinding is
aimed at, if but if not
provoking some kind of Ukrainian
military actions in the Donbass, then at
least
to cover the line of the Kiev regime for
complete sabotage low agreement
I don’t see any other explanation today, we
frankly talked to Tony Blinken about this,
he agreed that, in general, it is
necessary, of course, to conduct a more reasonable
dialogue and
I hope that emotions will decrease, although
there are no guarantees
and the weight was
formed
facades I’m yours for
babies and called to  such we have
from they are right sizes over energy was the
character a
tool of high f  or this work of the
starvation 12 rows until retirement Anya and Misha
ate bat by Danish Tenzin ona shesta dance
ignashin trudi pro